nathalie bono est une peintre un peu
originale pour déployer son art pas de
pain sommet du scotch pas de peinture
mais des magazines à première vue
difficile d'imaginer quelle technique se
cache derrière ces tableaux quand je
vais prélever la lettre elle en
plusieurs parties les lettres et motifs
de ces revues ce transfert et s'imprime
sur son ruban adhésif puis sur sa toile
une technique bien personnelle et
surtout accidentelle qui remontent à
l'époque de ses études aux beaux arts
d'orléans
hier soir je me suis retrouvé avec une
impression sur un scotch et j'ai fait ça
très intéressant et j'ai continué c'est
parti de là est depuis ce temps là je
dirais pas graphiste à la ville cette
charte rennes a fait de l'alphabet son
terrain de jeu en 38 sont créatrices et
montage mais lui mettrais elles vident
les mauvais caractère de leur sens pour
en faire des motifs esthétiques
la lettre qui me sert pour tous qui
communication passer le message et l'âge
de la des structures je la travaille
comme graphiste c'est pas même message
là je laisse les gens allaient à leur
découverte se fait aller au rythme ont
rythmé aux ambiances que je leur propose
dernière lauréate du prix de la ville de
maintenon au salon artistique de la
vallée de l'eure elle expose dans ce
bâtiment historique
une partie de son oeuvre nehili à
bientôt 35 ans et son univers semble
séduire les visiteurs
c'est surprenant on croirait presque qui
a eu un vernis d'apposer dessus et pas
du tout c'est uniquement les faits du
scotch c'est vraiment surprenant c'est
très harmonieux c'est très très
artistique très
et chacun peut y voir un peu ce qu'il
veut on a fait le touche toutes les
ombres pas forcément les mêmes choses
l'exposition se poursuit tout le week
end en présence de l'artiste qui
n'hésite pas à dévoiler les petits
secrets de ses tableaux